[Musique]
faris est super beau ici comme clichy
oui bah parlent maintenant
bah après on avait rendez-vous donc je
suis là je voulais savoir comment je
m'inspire non pas forcément du coup si
du coup voilà comment je m'inspire je
pense que tu peux m'inspirer de ma façon
de mieux dans sa tête et que je regarde
de ses oeuvres
je cherche caisse créée dans mon esprit
et communique avec
et les vins de secret quand je
communique avec avec dollar j'ai largué
communique avec de l'art de deux
semaines voilà je te propose d'essayer
communiquer avec dollar
bonsoir à tous je m'appelle non non aux
hommes que je mettais des villes cultes
en fait c'est tout était débile de
nationaliser quoi en fait tout le temps
tu petit levier un petit peu si je t'ai
fait venir l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles tu es là c'est que je veux
que tu arrêtes avec les mots super
content sa phrase début trois angles de
phrase je les gens peu plus d'une super
équipe et paris c'est quand même comme
ça que j'aime connaître c'est comme ça
que je me reconnaître dans la rue je
voudrais tu veux pas les gens te
reconnaissent grâce à ton visage
d'accord
et tu parles de les élever un petit peu
c'est gentil riz un petit peu vers le
haut feller voir autre chose je te parle
de augmenter le prix des places ah oui
c'est pas cultive toi un petit peu de
lit des choses voir autre chose je lis
ou julie enrichit un petit peu ton
vocabulaire c'est de ça que je te parle
super
et c'est gargantuesque à la place de
super oui pas en plus de créer une
chaîne de mou
est-ce grandes choses qu'on a les
mêmes ça tu te rends médiocre j'ai
essayé
quelle médiocrité
je pressens pression' et
merci
[Musique]